[Music]
pared down new year's eve celebrations
the world over
after a year like no other auckland the
first major city to ring in 2021
after the pacific island of tonga with
no restrictions on gatherings
new zealand's the only country to have
beaten covert 19.
sydney's spectacular fireworks though
reduced to just seven minutes
viewers encouraged to stay at home the
harbour itself a ghost town
masks and disinfectant on show in japan
for the new year tolling of the bells
but the emperor has cancelled his
traditional address after an end-of-year
covid spike
a very different story in north korea
the north korean leader kim jong-un
omnipresent
as ever claims the country has never had
a single case
and then to china where it all began new
year's wishes from the people of wuhan
the chinese president xi jinping thanked
his people for their courage in the face
of covert 19.
from medical workers to the people's
army from scientific researchers
to community workers from volunteers to
those who built the projects
from seniors to youths born after the
1990s and 2000s
numerous people fulfilled their missions
at the cost of their lives
and protected humanity with sincere love
they pooled their drops of strength into
tremendous power
and built an iron wall to safeguard
lives
but that wall was not strong enough hong
kong's fireworks
display is cancelled instead all
festivities are virtual
and in most european cities the
traditional new year fireworks aren't
happening
the german chancellor angela merkel in
her last new year's address to the
nation
had this to say
2020 was one of the strangest years in
living memory
a wave of sickness washing across the
globe bringing trauma
and economic turmoil as the seconds tick
down till midnight
may 2021 be a better year for us all
dinah magnay sky news